the residential population of the
Waimakariri district has expected to
reach 63,000 by 2025 most of that growth
is expected to occur in the east of the
district planning and catering for that
growth were priority issues for the
council during 2015 and 16 to replace
the earthquake demolished kaya boy
service center and to cater for the
town's expected growth Rua tonific I
oppose Civic Center was completed in
2015 at the national property industry
awards in 2016 this building one the
best in category award in a special
purpose category
[Music]
in rhaggy aura the new retail and
business development at Conway Lane was
a joint public-private partnership
Council owns the laneway itself and
private landowners have developed the
buildings on either side the development
is complementary to the concepts
outlined in RTC 2020 the Rangi aura town
center strategy in oxford the earthquake
strengthened remodeled and refurbished
Oxford town hall was reopened by the
prime minister in 2015 after several
months closure following the earthquakes
of 2010 and 11
[Music]
during 2015 we looked at ways that our
communities could be better represented
in the district we asked for your views
about Ward boundaries the future of
community boards and the ideal number of
elected members there are now three
wards in the district renamed to reflect
the population areas they represent they
are the rainy or a Ashley ward the kaya
Point would end Ward and the Oxford
Oaxaca ward
there are now two community boards
representing the kaya poi wooden Ward
they are the wooden siftin community
board and the kaya poi to a he we
community board you can see detailed
information on the council's activities
in 2015 and 16 by looking at the annual
report and summary on the council
website